he's uh the NBA insider for USA Today
Sam Amick he also writes for the
athletic and he joins us now his recent
column
spits padded staples an account of what
happened before during and well after
the Lakers rockets fight good morning
Sam thanks for joining us how are you
Dan I'm doing great I actually made the
full switch my friend athletic called me
at this point but USA Today was great
for me but I appreciate you admin
alrighty
tell me what happened before the fight
between the Rockets and Lakers so well I
mean it depends honestly how far back we
want to go we could do a whole show
talking about raison rondo and Chris
Paul and and you know the more you pull
the onion the layers back on the onion
on that relationship the more you get
reminded that these are two guys who
just have not liked each other for a
long time you know you have stuff with
Team USA
I believe in 2008 where Chris Paul was
getting a spot on the team that Ronda
thought he deserved
you have fisticuffs in 2009 or at least
you know tension in a New Orleans Boston
game where after the game came to an end
you know they got into it a little bit
and so you have two guys who have
chirped at each other for a long time
and you hear things about how
essentially Rondo would get under
Chris's skin by by it by going down the
road of like I have a championship the
type of thing you want and you're never
gonna get and he would get in his head
in that way and then Chris would say you
know I mean listen he's the far superior
point guard and then we would kind of
have an air about him of you know I'm
the king and a point guard mountain so
to speak so these guys didn't like each
other and you know that day in the game
if I had to highlight one play more than
any other it was the one in the first
half where Chris Chuck's Rondo as he's
driving from the right side Rondo goes
flying and you know as a strong play on
Christmas part and after he you know
Rondo doesn't get the whistle Chris gets
the bucket
Chris flexes twice to the crowd and kind
of plays that up a little bit and for
what I heard Rondo from that point on
would not stop talking to Chris and and
and you know the sparks kind of started
flying at that point do you think Rondo
spit on him
I I do I mean listen its technology is
an incredible thing and yesterday when I
get the video of that situation you know
we've seen a ton of video on Twitter and
social media already obviously but you
know when you have a 200 megabyte video
that we got our hands on at the athletic
and I'm looking at a high-res laptop
screen where you can just sit there and
watch Rondo appear to kind of check his
his you know his left side real quick -
almost as if he was you know seeing if
official Jason Phillips was within you
know kind of I shot if he was gonna see
him and then you see you know still spit
whatever you want to call it come out of
Rhonda's mouth and and go towards Chris
I mean that minimum if you put yourself
in Chris's shoes it's that idea that you
know that Rhonda's that just landed on
you you can't judge intent but at that
point Chris doesn't care you just spit
on me and that's always gonna be a
trigger I'll be surprised Ingram only
got four and even Rondo if even if it's
accidental spit I would have given him
more just for that gesture Paul I
understand retaliating you're gonna pop
him for a couple of games Ingram with a
cheap shot there where somebody really
really could have gotten hurt and the
fact that Rondo spit on Chris Paul did
the NBA get it right with the
suspensions in your opinion I think they
would like to be honest with you I'm a
little surprised by some of the feedback
within the league in fact last night I
went out to the Clippers rockets came
and caught up with Doc Rivers a little
bit afterward and I wanted to get Doc's
opinion on that question if he thought
it was light and if as a coach you had
any concern across the league that you
know if you put yourself in the players
shoes are they still gonna have the
mentality of and nobody wants to fight
in this league because they cost you so
much money so on the one hand yeah I
know it still cost these guys a lot of
money but I feel as if the league is
playing that card too much meaning you
know they will they will tell the media
like hey listen Chris lost X amounts
Branden lost action
it's a lot of money but these guys make
an incredible about and I think the
player perspective more likely is
alright if I have a problem in a game
and I'm really upset with the guy now in
my head like I'm probably gonna get two
games and I think maybe I'm ok with that
because this dude is really ticking me
off like I you know that's where I my
head is that I think it could lead to
more on the court stuff doc disagreed
doc thought that they essentially got it
right and that you know they didn't need
to go any harder
this might good for the league uh it
almost depends on what comes next in a
vacuum yes but you know what it made me
think of Dan and this is maybe a reach
is you know I'm not a UFC guy so
apologize if I get any of the details
wrong but like them the McGregor you
know cubby you situation like like you
know when you have controversy when you
have over the top you know stuff like
this entertainment wise entertainment
value speaking it's it's great for that
entity because it draws interest I get
in a you know a car yesterday to just
get a lift ride to the arena and the
guys talking to me about what happened
everybody's talking about what happened
so the NBA is front and center but you
know if it does open that door to more
stuff like this then you have it becomes
a turn-off to a certain audience and
then business-wise you I think you end
up taking it down a negative Road I know
it's a small sample size but the product
on the floor for the Lakers what uh what
do you like what concerns you I like the
athleticism I like you know that the
tempo the it honestly is a guy who it's
a lot of it's weird we almost in the
media we're afraid to use the word fun
like can't ever admit that you're having
a good time it is fun to watch the
impact that LeBron has on other
basketball players so I think that is
enjoyable because you already see the
ripple effect of his presence but the
you know what I don't like shooting an
obvious problem defense going to be a
problem lack of big men obviously a
problem leaning on JaVale McGee way too
much I
credit for having carved out the career
that he has at this point I mean the
guy's got rings the guys now playing
with LeBron that's fantastic but you
know the other night in that game you're
looking at it and offensively I mean
they were featuring JaVale I know pretty
routine you know it's what are we
looking at here and and I'm not even
trying to play that card of you know
he's not a punch line but look who's on
the floor like what would we were
featuring Jamil and then he's playing
big minutes and then you know so that
those are problems and they're I think
honestly in terms of the context of this
season this is this is just really a
disaster for them right now
when you're losing Rondo and Ingram the
way they are and maybe getting off to a
really tough start because when we would
all debate about whether or not the
Lakers were gonna make the playoffs and
everybody thought we were crazy for
saying maybe they don't like what was
the whole subplot like you can't get off
to a bad start
in the Western Conference you can't
recover like you can in the East and
right now they're facing that kind of a
prospect I'll leave you with this that a
few whispers they're about LeBron James
leaving Cleveland and maybe it was you
know he'd lost a little tread off the
tires here and I kind of kicking him on
the way out what do you make of these
whispers about LeBron and his abilities
his talent level now I mean that's
that's the league I mean that happens
every time a guy heads for the exits you
know I'm not seeing it you know the guy
is in an incredibly high level and you
know he's still the best player in the
game and I think the other thing we're
gonna be looking at just all year long
is is forget about how the Cavs or the
media might see a talent level it's out
of his peers see his talent level and
who's gonna come join him next summer
that's the number one thing he's got to
find a way to paint a pretty enough
picture in LA to make sure that you know
whoever it might be Anthony Davis you
know all the other usual suspects that
might come next summer he's got to
finish that job because if he doesn't
it's gonna be a lonely Laker experience
and you know and again the West is just
so unforgiving that he's got to get back
part of the equation done but do they
make a deal do they I talked to Chris
Weber about this last hour he said you
got to prevent yourself from
overreacting if you're not playing great
or you're on the outside of the playoff
bubble and you make a deal I wouldn't do
anything this year unless I got somebody
that I thought was gonna help me big
picture long term I don't want you know
some band-aid to come in to help me make
the playoffs and we're the seventh seed
you got a plan stick with the plan and
don't run that risk do you think that
the Lakers make agree I would I mean I
would agree and I think the list of guys
who would check both boxes is probably
pretty short which is to say you know
would be part of the long term plan but
also some that you do right now I mean I
there's I have no intel to indicate that
they're in on the Jimmy Butler stuff at
all and like you know that type of a
player conceivably would be the road you
go down because you know you get an
early crack at him as far as a
perspective free agent like a Paul
George situation in Oklahoma City but
yeah you can't do any band-aids at all
this season and they have a luxury which
still amazes me that not only did they
get LeBron James
but they got LeBron James coming in the
door being very patient and sending the
message to them that I don't want you to
just go lose assets for the short term
gain the guy that I wonder about and
that there is already chatter about is
Londo you know because you have teams
around the league who are gonna look at
him and say man we can really have them
be part of our young core might be
willing to give you something of value
in return and you have to gauge that
value if a Rondo is going to play most
of the year and lot of those values is
going to go down then you got to take
that into consideration what if you said
you know what we'll give you
Lonzo for JJ Redick straight up I mean I
would think about it JJ even on the one
hand you know father time is something
you get a look at what JJ is playing
great but you know you see the way the
Sixers had got away from him a little
bit and you know to help mark out folks
come along I guess I can't have
three guys in the backcourt who can't
shoot so I mean it doesn't make sense
right for the 76ers we had a we had a
bet the other day I starting to
seasonally said who has more threes this
year Ben Simmons Markel folds and I took
mo Bamba well I don't believe I just for
just for kicks and giggles did you see
the video of Lance Stephenson the other
day when he he fired the three from the
right corner and and did the 360
celebration as if he knew it was falling
in and it wasn't even close to just
serene up and left out of the red I mean
that's Laker shooting right oh god Sam
thank you great talk to you again and
good luck with the athletic thank you
Dad Sam aiming I love his stuff the
columnist for the athletic used to be
with USA Today for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]